i've taken a lot of inspiration from
your
philosophy of good
how do you apply this without succumbing
to polyanism
did i say that right yeah so pollyannish
is
is a is a term and it actually comes
from a
from a novel from
i think it's like the early 1900s but it
it uh
the name of the novel is pollyanna and
anyways pollyanna in the book has this
really super positive attitude
and it's almost so positive that
it it overwhelms and it kind of changes
people's attitudes in the town
but there's a pejorative meaning of this
word which is what this guy's asking
about
and it is that is when when someone is
like soul
positive that they
that they forget about reality of a
situation
you know and so that's that's
that can be absolutely problematic and
that is not what i'm telling anybody to
do
in fact the the let's
let's not mistake the the good
philosophy
as one that negates reality that is
totally off that's not what i'm telling
anyone to do in fact the very first
thing you have to do
is accept reality that's the first thing
you gotta do you gotta look at what's
happening
you gotta assess it assess the reality
of it and then you say okay
good now instead of dwelling on the
negatives and what's gonna go bad and
what's wrong
you deal with them but then you look at
okay now what are we gonna do
positive out of this what good's gonna
come out of this
and that's that's all it is it's
definitely not denying or being
delusional about the situation by any
stretch
but it is also not being woe is me
and oh this happened and now oh my gosh
everything's going horrible i'm doomed
no that's that's not what i'm talking
about
obviously i'm not talking about that and
it's also not like it's okay
everything's wonderful no that's why the
term is
good and not wonderful right i'm not
saying everything's wonderful but good
okay now what are we gonna find out of
this what are we gonna figure out of
this what are we gonna make happen now
because i'm gonna deal with reality i'm
gonna accept reality i'm going to accept
reality yeah then there's some people
that you know
like the the self-help gurus that are
like no i'm just not going to accept
that
it's not going to happen make your own
reality i'm going to be so positive
that i'm going to get that million
dollars tomorrow you know no no actually
you're not gonna get that million
dollars tomorrow
you're gonna have to work you're gonna
have to work for a long time you're
gonna have to work hard you're gonna
have to stay focused on your goals
and then you'll get your million dollars
good see how strong you are
yes yes so
that's it deal with reality except
reality then find the good in it
and move forward
that's a cool video by the way that you
that you made
you like that video i do i think is that
you fishing for a compliment
that video is uh i think it's been a lot
of people watch that video
yeah it's interesting too because you
made that video
and you made another video where does
discipline come from
right and and i actually personally i
like the where does this
plan come from video better but
the good video it just strikes a chord
with people
right the at because i think i think
because it applies so universally
to negativity in the world like okay yup
these bad things are happening right now
in fact i get so much feedback of people
that literally say
you know thank you for introducing me to
that
idea that philosophy because it's
changed my attitude and now when things
go wrong
i say good now what am i gonna do about
it right so
i think that's why that video is is
quite popular
that and the unbelievable editing that
was done where it was put together
yeah sure yeah and it it does seem like
a real um
like personal like deeply personal thing
like
because it it's like it's more it's not
this like sensationalization
of it it's just it's real kind of kind
of dark whatever and
like how you said like the negative part
of it it's like a um i said this last
time or
it's a painkiller it's not a
multivitamin you know what do you mean
by that
meaning i've heard you say that before
meaning like if you have a problem
you you know okay just in nature when
you when you're going along whether your
brain is
is evolved to to recognize problems
and if something isn't a problem it'll
start to filter that out
that's just how your brain is okay so in
life when you have problems that's
what's always on the radar
now you have this little personal like
tool that's talking to you of how to
deal with those problems
nice you know i mean so um so the it's
it's kind of that like the discipline
where does this swing come from it's
kind of that's more
starts to go into the multivitamin thing
where it's like this is not a big
problem
i'm gonna try to recognize it as a
problem i need more discipline
you know but it's not really this huge
problem but it does help you know kind
of thing
so it's like a multivitamin interesting
um but i like the discipline one as well